all right so we all set yes all right
thanks for coming everyone uh my name is
Jimmy Bogard you can find me on Twitter
at J Bogard
um this presentation uh as well as the
code examples are on my GitHub I'll be
uh shooting out the links to the
specific repositories and stuff on my
Twitter
um and I've blogged about this topic and
a lot of other things on my blog at
jimmyboguard.com my day job is
Consulting so I typically are building
applications and systems for clients
that uh for some reason want to pay me
to do that sort of thing
um and I did a lot of Open Source stuff
uh Auto map or mediator to my big
projects so either I'm sorry or you're
welcome one of those two things
and this talk in particular came from uh
one of our clients that was going from a
monolithic application that was all
deployed on-prem moving towards a
microservice oriented architecture
deployed with kubernetes and in Azure so
like throwing every single technology at
the wall and seeing which one sticks
that sort of thing
and my team in particular was charged
with not only building some of these
microservices but at some point we had
to figure out how to secure them so this
talk is the story of how we design the
security of those different Services
talking to each other and how we were uh
how we then use Azure uh Azure security
features to be able to do so
but their existing system uh was built
in a much simpler time
um and there was just a it was a single
monolithic application that was just a
client server application so they had a
big asp.net web forms thing that sat on
servers on their uh on their Data Center
and then the clients were just browsers
and some mobile apps uh talking to these
servers
um and so for them it was pretty simple
like we just have you know the Internet
of Things We don't trust and then we
have our server of the things that we do
trust and they would just use cookie
based authentication and authorization
to secure those servers so you would log
in and in that cookie you had some
information about you
um I think they they should probably
shoved way too much stuff in that cookie
because like the cookie was too big but
in any case uh it was very kind of
straightforward set of security
um with this the cookie based
authentication and authorization
now as they move towards microservices
where they simplified things right
um it becoming it became a lot more
complex and to understand how we should
secure each of these different
connections between each of these
different systems and services
um so the new application they were
building
was no longer going to be a server-side
rendered web application you know like
MVC or anything like that is of course
going to be a spa and Spas by themselves
already are going to have more
complicated security requirements that
may not be completely obvious to really
anybody I think that uh that is looking
at for the first time so
um their architecture looks something
like this in the Azure space we had the
clients which is still going to be a
browser this is an angular application
that was talking to a single API
endpoint and this is using the bff or
back and for front-end uh pattern and so
that API was purpose built for those
individual clients
now those BFF apis did not have any
state by themselves their job in life
was to aggregate back-end data into
coherent responses for the front ends
there's different there's different ways
you can do those apis like BFS BFFs are
are ones that are very specific to the
application calling them but you could
also have API gateways which are more
generic so you have different
applications calling it in this one API
or you can use Technologies like graphql
that can be that that API that is for
your for your browser
um so the complicated thing here is uh
we could we could figure out the the
authentication and authorization between
the client and that BFF and even could
be very similar to our server-side web
applications uh what wasn't so clear was
what do we do about all these uh all
these other things behind the scenes
um so the first thing they had to figure
out was how do we authenticate and
authorize external users so the people
uh using the browser how can we
authenticate how do we know who you are
and what kind of things you can do
um their existing application use that
cookie based authentication but it was
all completely baked into that system
and we could make it portable to
something else and so they wound up
going
um with auth0 and external identity
provider for those those the
authentication of those users
okay but this talk is not about all zero
it's about Azure and so we still had to
figure out uh what do we do behind the
scenes here so someone uh I don't know I
think an Osteo service sales rep like uh
you know went on a golf course and
convinced them to buy out zero because
it's it's quite expensive to use
um but it can help solve a lot of those
like you know single sign-on sort of
problems
so he said okay that's great uh off zero
it'll take a few years for that to roll
out so we can't necessarily even count
on it for a back-end service
communication
um so we need to figure out how do we
secure all the things behind the scenes
here how to be secure once I get past
that first initial API call how do I
then circuit the communication of all
these different microservices behind the
scenes and then we also have the added
complication of on-prem servers also
needing to call into our microservices
for those kind of Legacy systems the
Legacy applications that were still out
there
so there are two big questions we had to
answer was one how should we approach
securing internal Azure communication so
I want to have once something deployed
in Azure calling something else deployed
in Azure how do we secure that
communication and the answer is probably
not nothing like probably probably do
some kind of authentication and
authorization probably don't just leave
it open to anyone to be able to call
and the second thing we're looking at
was how do we how do we secure on-prem
applications calling into our
microservices
now I'm not a networking person uh so
I'm not going to talk about that at all
because I will screw it all up we did we
also had very smart networking people
that knew how to do the network key
stuff uh I don't know subnets and v-nets
and vpns all that sort of junk I don't
know any of that stuff so like just
assume that that was all like there and
figured out but not by me what we needed
to do was okay let's say we can we can
still have these two systems you know
secured behind the scenes and not open
to the public well I still don't want to
necessarily just open up those apis to
be called by anybody
this client in particular uh was dealing
with personal information and Health
Data and so we had to be very very
careful about who we were going to be
giving out that data to especially in
the states I'm sure it's the same as
here here as well there's a lot of
privacy laws and data protection laws
that we had to adhere to and it wasn't
good enough for us to say well we got it
secured to the front over there like the
the back and forth front end does the
security and then behind the scenes is
just you know Wild West anyone can go
anything we wanted to make sure that we
could still properly lock down those
apis so not anyone that was just on the
network could call these apis and get
access to that personal health
information
so one of the ideas uh
um that's uh our security team uh really
like latched on to and wanted to
implement as part of this was known as
the zero trust model
um which is this idea of of uh not just
assuming because you you made it past
this certain points that that's good
enough I don't have to do any further
authentication or authorization
um instead with this idea of zero trust
models that I don't ever I don't just
trust any call that's made into me that
I always want to verify those individual
calls
now this is something like again if
you're a security consultant you're
probably making Bank off of this kind of
concept because it's very like vague and
nebulous and it's hard to say what does
it actually mean in practice to do this
kind of thing
um so we said okay we'll we'll do that
okay we'll do the zero trust thing but
then what does that actually mean in
practice to always verify each
individual step along the way
one possible way of doing this would be
to say well we've already got this token
for the front-end user they've already
authenticated and have this this token
that can expire and can't be spoofed to
things like that so why don't we just
quote
um just flow that user token down into
the backend microservices so that's I
don't have to come up with some other
new authentication method behind the
scenes instead I could just use what
they've already got like just use this
token and then pass it along to the next
one down the line
uh the problem with that well there's
two two main problems uh one
um because I'm using the same token in
my microservice that is being used by
the front end that could mean that a
front-end collar or an angular client
could call directly into my back and
microservices and that's not something
we wanted to allow like even though the
you know like maybe we've made sure the
networking pieces that it wouldn't be
possible
um but we didn't want to just say you
know if you have a token you can call
our apis uh because we didn't want we
didn't want to allow the external
clients to in any way shape or form be
able to call into our backend
microservices
the other problem we're running into
were these on-prem systems uh didn't
have a token like their existing uh
existing monolith that was using cookie
based authentication and authorization
they didn't have a token so we would
have to somehow like okay let's let's
make a token based on this cookie and
now I get a token to be able to call
into you and everything's good
um so that was like that was gonna be
way too complicated as well to try to
deal with like all these different
possible callers uh these different
possible scenarios
um because even though I just got like
three on-prem things there were actually
like I know five or six different
distinct authentication and identity
providers because of Acquisitions over
the years
so given all that like the uh the
security team said okay yes um to help
simplify things uh because we know that
you're deployed inside of azure
um we can use Azure security model to
see to authenticate and authorize those
inter-service communication calls
and so the various on-prem systems and
external clients would still use their
own identity providers to be able to
authenticate the users but then once we
were inside the Walled Garden of azure
and we were you know basically just
completely cut off we've cut off the
communication from external users in
that case we can use Azure security
model and for a number of reasons which
which we'll see shortly
so uh
yes
um we said great let's do Azure ID
um zero trust Azure D great and that was
given this design was given to my team
and I said okay then uh security team
how do we implement this and then I
heard like the rapid scurring of feet as
they ran out the door because they just
drew a picture of us it's like yeah just
use this model and it came time to my
team like okay how do we use this model
um this was a more conceptual idea from
them and our team had to actually
implement it
so
um the first thing we had to figure out
was well if I have service a wanting to
call service B
and service B needs to have a I want to
have some kind of token that says this
is calling this is calling from service
a and I know it's this identity of
service a uh we need to figure out how
to First authenticate that service a to
begin with
now Azure ID supports a variety of
authentication flows and the ones that
we were looking at a particular were
oauth 2.0 flows
and I am not an oauth experts they're
they're a lot of people much smarter
than me about this but me my team we had
to implement this so we had to look at
this and try to figure out okay well uh
what what is the right way for us to
even acquire a token like of 1.0 has
some pretty simple ways of doing so
oauth 2.0 its authentication flow has
become a bit more complicated
now one thing that's a little bit
different with Azure ad with some other
identity providers and this client also
was using identity server now duende
those can support like really any kind
of authentication flow you want what
Azure ID tries to do though is try to
guide you down the correct paths for
these different kinds of authentication
flows so for some of these
authentication flows they won't allow
certain ways of calling into it to say
well you shouldn't be using this flow in
this kind of scenario so we're just
going to not allow it at all
so um their docs uh describe here the
different kinds of flows you can have or
the base are these different scenarios
and here's the oauth flow you should use
and then uh who are the kinds of
audiences that can acquire these kinds
of tokens
so he looked at this picture like okay
there's nothing that's like BFF
microservice scenario but we did see at
the bottom here well here's some two
here's two things that looks pretty
similar to what we're trying to do which
is I have a web API that calls other web
apis that's our backend for front and
API it is a thing that the angular app
is calling angular app calls the BFF API
and then that API is then calling our
microservice API so that looks like it's
the right one
uh we also have situations where we
don't have any user context
and uh or at least the user context that
we can use to acquire a token and so for
that it was a demon app that calls web
apis and so you can kind of think of
this like well what if you've got a
background service a messaging endpoint
or something like that where there's no
direct user interaction so there's not a
user logging in to do anything and so
for that one I don't have like a
username password I can use instead we
can use the client credentials flow to
do so
um now looking at the web API they calls
web apis uh we can we could use what's
known as the on behalf of flow and the
idea here is that when I call a first
API that API is going to call out to my
oauth provider my oauth server to
acquire a machine token on behalf of
this user token
so that way when I get to my backend
apis they're not they're not passing
through the user token because I don't
want to expose my backend apis directly
to the outside world instead they're
passing through this machine token that
was acquired on behalf of the original
token that was provided
now this works great if I'm in this
audience of work or school accounts that
fun thing from Microsoft identity that's
like you're like when you use live.com
versus microsoft.com authentication I
don't know why those are still different
but those are the work or school
accounts or if you're in live.com that's
your personal account uh and that that's
who the original audience of the token
can be
but that's not us
we're not in Azure ID world and user
land and user land we were like
homegrown authentic authentication
provider that was probably like you know
Microsoft identity from asp.webforms
Days uh and so that just had a cookie so
I didn't have uh I don't have a token to
begin with
um and in the front inside this this new
angular application uh was using
initially identity server and was moving
moving to uh off zero so those are two
completely different identity providers
neither of which are Microsoft so he
said great although we're like supposed
to use the on behalf of flow that's out
because we can't acquire a token on
behalf of like a token that's not
Microsoft so that left us at the very
end with just the client credentials
flow and last time I gave this talk
someone came up to the ends like so the
moral of the stories just use client
credentials I'm like well well yeah um
but
um again that's easier said than done
because uh these oauth credential flows
really only talk about Authentication
that does not describe authorization
that is who and in these different flows
how do I make sure that I don't let
anyone with a token even if it's a valid
uh uh valid Microsoft based Azure ID
token I don't want any application to be
able to just call into my my apis
because we are dealing with this
um this this legally protected
information Health Data personal data
that sort of thing
so um our next
uh thing we need to figure out was how
do we then authorize these different
applications to be able to call our apis
so how do we make sure that only the
right apps are the ones that can do so
and this is one that uh oauth 2.0
doesn't have any recommendation for like
it's completely up to your application
how you decide to authorize individual
apps calling other apps and so all the
different identity providers really have
like their own like made up way of doing
so so if you go look at auth zero it
supports client credentials flow if you
want to do authorization to say like
only this API can call that API and not
just anyone with a token from this
issuer they have their own like made up
way of doing so a lot of people use
claims so like I uh I say I want to call
this other API and then I'm issued a set
of claims but again that's something
that you just have to completely make up
yourself you have to design that for uh
what for what you want to do
or
um
for Microsoft talks they they have like
they have two main ways you can do this
uh the first one they had was an access
control list and I was like oh that's
kind of cool you have a you have these
ACLS that you define like who who are
the who are the appropriate apps that
can call into me
um but they don't have any necessarily
they don't have any support of actually
configuring this inside of azure it's
like no no when you do ACL it is not 100
your client code and API code that has
to say who or who is calling me and are
they the right person
so for simple systems this can work if I
say like I know that these are my three
callers that are allowed to call me I
can just look at the token and say well
you're one of these three people and
then somewhere in my application
um in my configuration I have the list
of these are the three people that can
call me and no one else but it's just
like 100 custom logic about what you
actually do there
something that
um Microsoft supports though is this
idea of application permissions
and uh when we go the application
permission routes then we are actually
configuring uh the secured resources
inside of azure to be able to do so so
if I'm on the left it's 100 custom code
in my application and in the right it is
configuration inside of azure ID to
build this out
so
um these application permissions we can
Define custom they're called roles
whatever but they're they're permissions
and then we assign those roles to
specific principles
um and then when I acquire a token for
for service a calling service B service
a will ask uh Azure ID to say hello I am
service a I want to call service B
Azure ID looks up and says who uh well
based on service a which roles or
permissions have you do you have
assigned to service B and then the token
that comes back will then contain the
roles assigned to service a for service
B
and in this way instead of having like
these kind of generic
um claims that don't necessarily do like
are tied to individual callers instead
what we can have is very specific uh
role assignments to say
um the service a you can call these
different kinds of things but service C
you're not allowed to have that much
access to data because you're going to
be using this purpose so you only have
these specific role permissions assigned
to you
and then on the server side when it
receives that request the server will
then actually do the code to authorize
the individual roles
now in terms of like which one of these
kinds of ways of doing things is better
it is really specific to uh you know
your domain and your application
um that's like one is necessarily better
than the other there's going to be
trade-offs to each of these approaches
for us though we knew that uh because we
are had protected Health Data
um that we knew that some apis that we
built would have more I guess more
protected data than others so if you
were calling an API that doesn't have
that protected data we let more people
in to be able to call that but if you
were wanting to get that protected
health information and personal
information they said well we don't want
to let anyone be able to call this we're
going to authorize these specific
applications to be able to call us
because we knew that those applications
could then do the extra kind of business
logic to hide specific data based on
lots of crazy business rules
so for us that's what we we thought okay
let's do these permissions because then
that lets us have much more granular
control about who which specific
applications are authorized to call my
apis
So based on that picture
we built out a greatly simplified
application and we could we could get it
down to basically just this kind of
these these kinds of clients and these
kinds of servers so in this much
simplified scenario we we got rid of all
like the kubernetes stuff because I
don't want to deal with that stuff
anyway and we had this this greatly
simplified picture where we have the two
different kinds of clients one is a
client deployed inside of azure and then
we have another client deployed outside
of azure and for me outside of azure is
just going to be
this laptop here and then our server
will also be deployed inside of azure as
well the server and the Azure client are
just going to be Azure app services to
make my life a bit simpler and then the
external client is just going to be a
console app on my laptop
all right
um so we said great let's do this uh
roll based off with these permissions
and so the next thing we needed to do
was to Define what those permissions
should be and this is a design decision
that we had to make as the people
defining the system how granular or
coarse grain should these roles be and
again even though they're called roles
inside of azure in practice we Define
them words like permissions to perform a
specific kind of activity and the
built-in roles inside Azure ad as well
mapped to that as well
so this API uh that we're going to have
for our demo
um is just a to-do API so I can get all
the two items I can get a single to do
item I can update a to-do item I can
create a to-do item or I can delete a
to-do item and I chose this example
because I could find the code for it on
the internet and I can use it and not
have to come up with something myself
I'm just that lazy
okay so based on this
um we need to figure out well what what
kind of permissions should we Define for
each of these different API endpoints we
could Define a distinct permission per
individual thing you're trying to do so
I can have like a read like a crud right
read update create delete
and if I have other kinds of operations
as part of these things so if you needed
to like I don't know approve a to-do
item I could have like to do that
approve because that's a specific
permission
um so I did we did have to go back and
understand well what are the different
kinds of callers I'm going to have in my
applications uh and what is the kind of
the shape or surface area of those
different kinds of things they should be
called the more permissions I create
like the more control I have but then
the more over I had I will have to
maintain these to say like well if I
want to do these six things I got to go
Grant you permission for those six
things
so uh the other way to do is be a little
bit more coarse grained um and so we can
do something like
just read and write to say I have Sunset
some sets of applications that can read
and write data and they have other sets
of applications that are only allowed to
read data we don't want to allow them to
write that data
um and so for our actual real system
this is more the path we went through is
just looking at okay there's uh there's
like read there's write and there's also
like read protected like read protected
data or read Health Data
um and so we we basically shaped and
defined those permissions based on the
business use cases that we were uh that
we saw in our system
uh we can change these as well we don't
we can add new permissions we need to we
need to uh like go to a different role
or make it more grainler that's all
possible as well
all right
enough talk let's go look at a demo
all right now
I am doing the scary thing of doing an
Azure cloud-based talk on conference
Wi-Fi so let's all cross our fingers to
see how well this is going to work
but it was working just a few minutes
ago so hopefully it'll all be okay
all right
all right is this big enough for the
folks in the back
all right I can't see anything so I
guess it's okay
all right so this is my simplified
application system here I've got my
Azure clients that is an asp.net
6 app
that is deployed out into azure
I have my Azure server which is also an
asp.net6 app web app deployed into Azure
and then I have my external client which
is just a console application which is
only going to be running on my laptop
here
and the final thing I have here is in my
this infrastructure project
um it's can be very complicated to
understand how things relate to each
other inside of azure so I I when I
first did this I set up all these
different things using the Azure portal
um but once you're done setting
everything up you kind of forget like
what are all the things I clicked to
make this work I forget
um and so for us like my real team was
using terraform I I don't like that
weird language so I'm using uh pollumi
because hey C sharp one of the nice
things we can do with this is uh as
we're building out these resources
instead of me clicking around the portal
which can fail I'll be showing here the
resources in c-sharp code which are just
mapping the notes to uh Azure resources
this is not a talk about pollumi it's
just way easier to conceptualize things
when looking at code versus click click
click click inside the Azure portal
all right
so right now this API is not secured
whatsoever so if I go over to program CS
we can see that it does not have any
kind of like authentication or
authentication authorization but it's
not defined any kind of means of doing
so
um so I've not yet told it how it should
authenticate uh to be able to do
anything
and just to prove that these are
actually in Azure I've got this is my
clients on the free tier so please don't
go hit this it's it's very slow there we
go so I've got this actually deployed on
Azure but for a lot of this we just
running on my local laptop here
okay so uh we'll go back over to our
palumi infrastructure
and um the way plume works is uh you can
you can do this from the command line
where you say like you install the
client tools and you say pull me up it
will compile this application and then
based on the things I've defined on here
it will then create those resources out
in Azure I've already created all those
resources so I won't actually be
updating as we go we'll look at more of
the final product at the end because I
don't trust the speed of creating these
resources sometimes it can take just a
little bit of time
all right so in my stack
this palumi stack we created I created
just a a few things from the from the
get go to make my life a little bit
easier so the first thing I've created
is a resource Group
that everything is going to be under
um and then I'm also going to be
creating some app Services Under this
app service plan
all right so the first thing we're going
to do is in our server we're going to
define the Azure resources uh necessary
for both deploying the application and
also securing it
so let me go ahead and pull this over
first
[Music]
I was going to use a mouse
but this is slope like this and so the
mouse just kept falling down
all right so uh first up I've got
my Azure web app so this is an Azure app
service I'm going to be deploying
um and so this is the the actual
deployed application inside of azure the
only kind of interesting thing we have
here is like we're turning in HTTPS I'm
telling it what Resource Group uh where
the location should be which I think
right now is still like Central us
whatever and uh that when it runs it
should run.net azure server.dll
all right so that's just the running
application the next thing I'm going to
need
is going to be
the Azure ID components so for this
here
all right
so every like identity provider that
supports client credentials has
different ways of defining these
applications that I'm going to secure so
auth0 has its own like definition of
have like what are the different
applications and servers that could be
secured and Azure ID has its own way of
defining these things as well because
again auth0 defines a protocol it
doesn't Define like how you should
actually manage this behind the scenes
like how do I actually manage what are
the different applications what can call
each other that is completely up to you
and so or completely up to the identity
provider so in this case we are creating
what's known as a Azure ad application
called server application
and not a whole lot of information here
I'm just giving it a display name and
then some identifier Uris which when we
come when it comes time to actually
calling uh and trying to acquire a token
that's where the identifier URL will
become important
all right
so we said we needed to uh Define some
roles for this uh this application and
so I need to create that as part of this
as well so the next I'm going to do is
pull over some definitions of some role
IDs and so what these are each role will
have a have a unique identifier and I
need to refer that to identifier in
other places so I'm using plumy's random
uuid to be able to define those IDs so
they can more easily refer them to other
places
and then the final thing is to modify my
application definition to give it some
app roles so let me go and pull this
over here
okay so I'm still modifying the server
application and in Azure ID This Server
application this this Azure ID to
application object is just a way for me
to kind of group together and Define
like this is some kind of secured
resource that you want to apply some
logic to it is not actually something is
that something that's running somewhere
it's just a bunch of data about
something that you want to secure
all right so I've said I want to Define
two app roles one is to do that read and
the other is to do dot write
and so my to do dot read I tell it these
are the kinds of assignments you you are
allowed to have and so I have said that
you can assign this role to users and
you can assign this roles to
Applications
now I don't technically need that first
one users because these are applications
calling other applications however when
I'm testing this locally on my laptop
well I am a user and so I still want to
be able to call this API and have it
still go through all the authorization
so we'll also allow those roles to be
assigned to users as well
it's enabled here's the display stuff
and then finally the ID of the role I'm
giving it the value here if I don't give
it an ID here it'll just make something
up and they'll have to copy and paste
that made up ID all over the place so
here I'm defining the ID so that I can I
it's determine this thing I know exactly
what that ID is uh for that do the same
thing for rights to do that rights
at this point when I uh when I configure
this application or configure this uh
this resource I will have this Azure ad
example server application defined
inside of azure ad
and now I need to then in my server
actually authorize against this
information here
so let's now go over to our actual
server application
so over here
I've got that web API that we created
and right now it's not authenticating or
authorizing against Azure ad
and in order to authorize against Azure
ID I could do things manually right I
could go look at the jots coming in and
then I can look at the audience I can
look at the issuer and be like okay
these all kind of line up but to help
simplify things Microsoft has a library
so if I'm an API
they want to be secured with Azure ID I
can pull in this
microsoft.identity.web package to make
it much easier for my server API to
authenticate and authorize against Azure
ID
not required but makes my life quite a
bit easier because as we'll see
let's go back over here
I'll go and pull this over now to stick
this up top
needs to be down
here
we are going to say
builder.services.add Microsoft identity
web web APA authentication passing it in
our configuration
and so what that will do is for incoming
requests it will do the uh it'll it'll
it'll look at the token make sure that
it's against the correct issuer against
the correct audience and against the the
right subject all for me behind the
scenes and then all I have to do in my
configuration
is tell it what
I should authenticate here we go
all right so in this I will tell it's
the Azure ad instance and so I don't
have like my own custom Azure ID login
so it's just going to be the
login.microsoftonline.com
and then these next things tenant ID and
client ID
this is what's defined then in Azure ID
so the tenant ID is going to be the
tenants of your Azure ad directory and
then which is basically a bucket of
things you can secure and then the
client ID this is what's going to be the
first confusing thing of azure ID and
definitely won't be the last this is the
unique identifier of
This Server application thing here
so this right here is uh out Pops from
this we'll uh get a a unique identifier
and if I go over to my Azure portal
all right so so over here under Azure
active directory there's an app
registrations and this is the list of
applications they're also called out
called app registrations because
Microsoft likes to rename things every
three years or so uh so this these app
registrations are those applications
that have defined uh in Azure ID so I've
got my server here
and uh right here we can see this
application parentheses client ID and
this is the unique identifier of this
securable resource now this is not tied
to my app service right now like my app
service when it runs will raise its hand
and say hello I am this client
application ID and so whenever it
authenticates and authorizes those
tokens is going to be doing so Under the
Umbrella being this application
okay so over here in my app settings
Json we can see that the client ID is
F12 something and right here the
application client ID is F12 something
so
those line up
all right
um so this will authenticate calls being
made in but we wanted to add on top of
this some role-based authorization so
we're going to do that in our
controllers if I go to my to do items
controller controller we can see that
it's already doing the authorize so it
will you know do the do the thing to
make sure the token looks good but we
want to on each of our different
controller actions authorize the
appropriate role that we defined earlier
role being the permission
so over here this is a get so the get is
going to be the 2d.read yep this is
another git so that's a to-do.read
this is put so it's going to be to do
dot right
this is post to do.writes
and then
delete
oh
wrong place
it's way easier with the mouse
to do that right all right
so there's a few things that are going
to happen behind the scenes for us so
like my first encounter with role-based
authorization was that I was doing
cookie based authorization and it would
look at like the the roles assigned to
that identity and look at that sort of
thing so this is still doing that for us
underneath the coverage it is doing the
you know look at my identity look at the
roles on that identity however those
roles and your identity when you're
running get populated from the token
being passed in
so this
part here
program CS
um
this is just some funky thing to by
default it will map some weird claims
out to uh to my my my token or my my
identity
um so the little extra piece
configuration here I say the role claim
type is roles there's going to be a
Rolls claim we'll see here in a minute
in our token
um just an array of values and it will
take those values and then put them in
the the role in my identity when it
actually runs so in my controller you
notice I'm not like I'm not poking
around tokens at all I'm simply saying
authorize that you're in the uh that you
have this specific role to do that right
all right
so
um
I have these uh have these roles defined
but if I run the application
let me put it push the turbo button so
it runs faster
I just got Swagger UI running to help my
local testing of this API
and so if I call one of these apis try
it out
what's going to happen
oh
unauthorized
because I have not authorized
authenticated as me being running in
this browser
so the next thing we needed to figure
out was okay well when I'm deployed to
Azure or I know I can like have these
applications authorized permissions but
for me running locally
I still want to be able to call these
apis I don't want to turn security off
locally because then you know I'm able
to exercise those code pass so what we
wound up doing
was was uh we created additional Azure
ad resources uh with groups and then we
assigned like my user to that group and
then assign permissions to that group so
that when I as me Jimmy uh calling and
wanting a token for that API it will
return back the roles based on my group
that's been assigned application
permissions can be assigned to users
groups of users or other applications
and I'm the group of users
all right so let's get that set up
all right so back over in my server
definition over here
I'm going to be adding a couple other
things here the first I'm going to be
adding is a
scope definition so this uh oauth scope
definition is just there because when
I'm using this specific flow of calling
from a browser Azure ID only supports
Scopes to be able to say I want this but
we will get that scope but we'll also
get back our roles as well but it can't
just deal with only roles for reasons so
I have to create some made up scope that
I'm using just to be able to call this
API
the next piece is a bit big so I'll I'll
just bring it over and talk through it
yeah
all right
um again this is now this is still on
the in the vein of like every single uh
kind of identity provider we'll do this
slightly differently
um and so for this I am a uh I am the
Swagger browser app wanting to get a
token on behalf of me Jimmy
um for this API and so uh I have to uh
this is not something that's open by
default I have to configure this
application resource to allow this kind
of flow so I'm telling it okay you're
going to have an API
um because that's what Microsoft assumes
in their Azure ad application definition
is that if you are wanting to support
this kind of flow then you must be an
API whatever but what this is really
doing though is uh enabling a specific
kind of oauth flow
um the auth code flow
and so I'm going to say okay you have
this set of permission Scopes the name
of this the uh this scope is called
local Dev for whatever reason and then
here's the ID of that that local Dev
the idea of the local Dev
scope ID yes there we go
all right
um the last piece I need to do
is in order for you to assign
permissions to this application we have
to graduate our application into
something that is now securable inside
of azure ID
in the portal these are known as
Enterprise applications uh I don't know
why that's just the name of them some
Legacy reason I'm sure and so we have to
graduate our API to something that can
be now something they can have
permissions assigned to it so a few
things I pulled in here
first of all is the defining a service
principle and the service principle you
can kind of think is like that root
table that my roles have to join to to
have them assigned and so this service
principle I'm saying uh give me whatever
name and saying the application ID that
this service principle is tied to is the
server application
and so when I run this in palumi that
makes this little link show up where it
says managed application in local
directory if I did not Define this
managed app or this uh this managed
application it would not have that link
and then it couldn't assign uh I
couldn't assign roles to This Server
okay the next thing uh is a really wonky
thing
um which is when I
uh when I as the browser wants to
acquire a token
um it wants to uh Define a specific
audience about who is calling that API
and so there's a there's a well-known
client ID for visual studio there's a
well-known client ID for visual studio
code I went on client ID for the Azure
CLI so when I'm trying to acquire a
token for something else it will use
that well-known quote ID to be able to
do so
all right so I'm saying I'm
pre-authorizing this application with
this quote well-known ID that is just
baked into Visual Studio since like 2005
or something
and then I'm telling it to the
application object ID that it's going to
be authorizing so this is the server
application and then finally uh what are
the permission IDs that I want to
authorize you for and so that permission
ID is going to be my local Dev scope
that right there
all right so that would allow me to run
when I F5 visual studio and make a call
out to again a token this will make sure
that I can I have this those things
connected however me as the user still
don't have the appropriate permissions
to do so so while I may get a token I
might not have the right roles that come
back in that token
so for that I'm going to create some
methods here
all right
so I uh I made a couple methods inside
my palumi configuration here and what
these methods are doing is just making
it kind of easy for me to assign
specific kinds of permissions and so
here I've got two methods one to assign
read and one to assign rights and in
order to assign a permission to a thing
I need to know a few things one is what
do you want to call the thing so I've
got like this prefix and the name of who
I'm getting assigned to because the the
kind of distinct names inside of my
configuration
um and then I need to know
who am I assigning this permission to
who was that principal that will receive
this and again who can I assign
permissions to or roles users groups of
users or other applications so I need to
know what is the principal ID of that
thing I'm trying to assign the role to
so that's it can basically create this
this uh this record here or this
resource here which is an app role
assignment that is I want to assign this
role
that it belongs to this principle to
this other thing
and when I've designed role-based uh
permissions and applications there's
some table somewhere right that is
here's the uh here's the here's a list
of principles here's the list of roles
and there's a join there and then
somewhere is going to be an assignment
table of which permissions are assigned
to which thing and that's that's
basically what this is it's creating a
row and a table somewhere that says uh
this role for this resource is assigned
to this other principle that's what that
is
so I got I have two methods one for the
to do dot read and then another one for
the 2D outrights and then I will Define
another method here which is
assigning the role
for the Azure ID resources and the Azure
ID resources is just my user and the
local Dev group that I've created
earlier now this is not something that's
specific to my application so some
probably like an admin or somewhere gets
a support ticket that says I need to
create an Azure ID group okay great and
then you need to assign these people to
that group okay great
um and so that's what this is this set
of resources are is just I want to
create a group that makes it easier to
manage you know who can get these local
Dev permissions and then I'm going to
assign me
to that group
this is probably not done via polumi in
your organizations or IAC it's probably
going to be like a service ticket
someone has to go in and actually do
this
in any case
um I want to assign the read and write
role to the local Dev group
service principle
finally over here on my stack I need to
actually call that method that I've
created so after I've created the server
client and the external client resources
I'm going to assign the roles
for the Azure ID resources
all right
the last thing so once I've run this it
will assign the local Dev group to those
resource those permissions and over here
I can actually see that if I go click
the application registration
the Enterprise application there's a
users and groups
anybody can see that my local Dev group
has been assigned the write and read
role which is really permission
all right so
um that will ensure that those groups
are assigned but I still have to tell
Swagger how to authorize so back in my
application here
I'm going to modify the Swagger options
to
authorize appropriately with Azure ad
and oauth 2
auth code flow
and so that's this configuration here I
have to tell it's the URL what to
authorize the token URL and what this
will do is when I run this it'll now
introduce that little padlock in the
Swagger UI so that I can authenticate
inside my browser against Azure ID
and the final thing down here is the
modifying the UI to do its thing as well
and so I tell it's you know you there's
your client ID the scope separator space
because reasons and then also to use the
pkce way of doing auth code flow again
this is just for local development
usually I would turn those off when I go
to production because like Swagger's
turned off altogether but this is just
for my local development
so now when I run
I get a nice little padlock
eventually
ah authorize
I go click that
and down here it's a little difficult to
see but it says let me bump it up
the scope that I'm going to Define is
local Dev because it'd have to make
something up for this code to be for
this flow to get all my claims back so
that's just kind of a made-up scope my
client ID of course is
F12 I think that's the visual Studio One
and then I click no no I'm sorry that's
the server I click authorize
if I was not logged in to microsoft.com
or live.com whatever you would get that
like login screen pick the account that
you want to use so you're this person
and then it comes back
and then I hit close so now when I hit
get I try this out
executes
let's oh it actually succeeded this time
200 so here's my two items and let's
grab this token doot
and go to jot MS
token and ta-da there are my roles
those show up because my user is a
member of that local Dev group and I've
assigned those two roles those
permissions to that local Dev groups
when I ask for a token it's going to
give me back all the claims that I have
for that resource and me as Jimmy uh
Jimmy Bogard I have this made up scope
of local Dev which I don't care about
but I also get back my roles so when I
call that API I've got those roles and
it will authorize those roles against
those different API endpoints and I can
actually do local Dev huzzah
all right
so at that point my server is secured
like it's good to go I can deploy that
out and I now can uh you know if I can
now do role-based authorization against
any kind of client the next thing I want
to do is then uh Define the
authorization components for those two
clients the the external clients as well
as the Azure client
now the external clients again is just a
console application here
um
because I'm going to use client
credentials flow there are a few
different options for my clients to
obtain those credentials one is with a
client ID and secrets that can be
rotated so I can say like it's got some
secrets and then you know if I want to
expire that secret I can create a new
one and then expire the old one or you
can use certificates in my actual
systems we were using certificates but
that's such a pain to create and set up
that I didn't want to do that so instead
I'm just using client ID and client
secrets
all right so in our client application
our external client
we're going to first bring over the
application definition
this is now the application definition
of the client now it's kind of funny
because like I'm defining these Azure ID
resources but this client is not running
in Azure but it's just using Azure ad as
that token provider and the identity
provider someone wants to acquire token
like I am resource a one to acquire a
token for resource B it's just calling
out to Azure to do so so these are the
the Azure ID components to get put all
that together
so I first need to create an application
but this time this is the external
client application
I also Define an application secrets
so I've got an application password for
the secrets then I'm going to
not show you but I put into user secrets
in visual studio and when I'm running in
Azure then I've probably got some
configuration up there to store the
secrets no I'm not running an Azure you
would store it in some secure way
in order to assign different roles to
different things I need to have a
principal associated with this
if I don't want to assign roles to
things I don't need a principal but I do
want to assign roles for this client
application so I need that
and then for the external clients
I need to configure some things as well
there we go so I'm going to pull in some
configuration for the external clients
and this external client
s
lots of stuff here it's going to be
making API calls out to this the Azure
server but when it does so I want to
make sure that it is able to acquire a
token appropriately and so I'm bringing
in let's see what is this Library it is
the Microsoft identity client so if I am
a client want to acquire token of from
Azure ID I can use that library to do so
um I'm using typed HTTP clients with
some middleware and that middleware is
going to include an ability to acquire
tokens so this middleware this client
authentic application auth Handler will
before it makes a call out
will
call acquire token from clients this is
from the Microsoft identity client
Library it'll acquire a token based on
the application ID that I want to call
and it will get basically all of the
all of the different uh claims for that
application ID
then it will get the result of that put
it in a bearer token so then when you
actually call the API it's it's putting
that bear token on the authorization
headers as it goes out the door
so now my client application my external
clients will be able to call Azure ID to
get a token to then call out to my
server
however uh we're still like quite there
yet we still need to assign those roles
for that client to the server so back
over in my server
I'm going to add another overload for
sign roles which is this and for this
external client I trust it less and so
I'm only going to be assigning the read
permission not the read and write
finally in my stack I will go ahead and
assign those specific roles there
all right so now let's run the server
and run the client
the external client that is
and return run the external clients a
bug
huh
and to make my life a little easier I'm
just going to log the token out don't do
this in production don't don't shove
your token in the log probably bad idea
that'll make my life a bit easier
because now I can take that
go back over to my browser go to jot
MS
and
now we see the token that my external
client got
only includes the to-do.read and it used
client ID client secrets to acquire that
token and so the the server
um the client the external client said I
am this external client I want to get
tokens for that server over there and
it's only going to return back the roles
that have been assigned to it
all right the last piece of the puzzle
is our Azure client
now something that's different in Azure
Land versus running externally is this
Azure has this concept of managed
identities and one of the things I can
do is have my application run as a
managed identity so they don't have to
use client ID Secrets or certificates I
can set assign roles to that managed
identity and that manage identity will
then be the thing that my application
runs like as
all right so let's do that
I'm going to go back over to my
[Music]
clients this is now the Azure clients
and I'm going to pull these pieces over
here I'm going to have
there it is
again this is running inside of azure so
I'm going to be defining an Azure app
service web app that's this piece here
and then it'll also be giving it a user
assigned identity so this is oops
this is a custom thing it always runs
under some identity but I'm going to
give it a user assigned identity
and I need to modify my app service
definition to say you need to run with
this identity so I'm saying you're going
to be running under a managed service
identity that is this user assigned
identity that I have right here
finally let's go ahead and output these
outs
so I'm just capturing those variables so
I can refer to them in other places
I need to go now to my server and assign
those roles so I'm going to create
another overload of assigned roles which
is
to assign that client
that internal Azure client will get both
the read and write roles
and then finally over in my palumi
stack
I will say server design roles
prefix and then decline as well so
my local Dev group gets read write the
external client only gets read and the
internal Azure client that runs in Azure
will only get uh will only gets the
we'll get read and write
now uh my Azure clients I have to do
something else to make it be able to
authenticate and authorize
so the first I'm going to do is get some
configuration in here
this is the last piece we're doing
okay so this client ID is now the client
ID of the application actually no it's
the ID of the managed identity because
that's who this client will be running
as in azure
and then over in my startup
where I've got this configure Services
stuff we've got
um that to pull in
so I uh in my Azure client if I'm an
Azure client's inside of azure talking
to other Azure Services we can actually
now use the azure.identity package you
may have seen this if using manage
identities to talk to key evolved or
Azure SQL things like that we can also
use the Azure identity Library if I'm an
Azure application to calling other Azure
applications I can use this as well
so hold back in my startup oops startup
I've got
huh
wrong place
I'm doing some similar configurations so
what my this Azure client is doing it's
a dumb API it is an API that just calls
the other API through a type HP client
this one is not secured so it's just
internally using the manage identity to
acquire the token to call the other API
so it's just completely open to the
internet here
okay so now uh when I run this inside of
azure I've got this up and going
this is my Azure client that's running
under a managed identity
and now when I make the call
to the server
it was successful so it successfully
acquired that token and now I'm going to
go over and grab
and my app services
the client
we'll go look at the logs and I can pull
the jot out of there
log stream
where's my log stream sound there we go
all right we'll make that request again
ah
where's that where's my token
there we go let me grab this token
pop it in my jots decoder
and sure enough I see that for this
application running under this managed
identity is be able to assign get these
different roles assigned to it when
acquired that token and then my code
itself was completely transparent so if
I look at my application code in my
controller I just have this typed HTTP
client but underneath the covers it is
going to be using Azure identity to
acquire that token so down here it says
uh
uh credential dot get token async it
gets the token for me and then all is
well and good in the world
so that was
securing microservices uh using Azure ad
um I know like the basically the moral
of the story was just use client
credentials
um what was interesting about Azure
though is that because Azure has this
concept of managed identities then all
of my Azure clients I don't have to
manage certificates or Secrets it is
completely transparent to me and I don't
have to worry about doing the
assignments for external clients though
because they're not running in like
Azure land then it will revert back to
either certificates or client secrets to
be able to acquire those tokens
so thank you very much if you want to
see the running example of this and pull
it down locally you can pull down this
uh this repository at the bottom the
Azure ID example you can run that
against your Azure uh
credits and stuff instead of mine to be
able to get it uh all running locally so
thank you very much I hope you all have
a great rest of the conference I'll be
sticking around for a little bit for
questions otherwise uh thanks
and please do uh don't forget to drop
the cards in there I do throw out all
the Reds if you drop anything there so
just